ich will dass sie nicht
geschafft beide teams haben das ziel
erreicht
berlin in der hauptstadt deutschlands
wartet die letzte große herausforderung
auf unsere sechs kandidaten die nord und
team südstaaten von unterschiedlichen
orten ihr unternehmen eine rikscha tour
fahrt aufmerksam durch die stadt team
süd beginnt am alexanderplatz es gibt
eine besonderheit die tickets die die
teams bei dieser aufgabe bekommen werden
mit ihren bisherigen tickets
multipliziert noch kann also jedes team
gewinnen
christina nasa und jonas sind im atelier
einer modedesignerin angekommen kathrin
engelke ist nach berlin gezogen und
gestaltet taschen gürtel und accessoires
berlin ist bekannt für seine vielen
design erleben
in der zwischenzeit ist auch team nord
aufgebrochen
ihre ganz persönliche berlin tour
startet am wittenbergplatz modena nicole
und eric sind zum ersten mal in der
deutschen hauptstadt als erstes halten
sie vor einer mensa schnell ein
erinnerungsfoto mit dem bären
schließlich ist er das wahrzeichen von
berlin team süd nimmt auch wieder fahrt
auf wirklich entspannen können sie
während der diktatur aber nicht denn
beide teams wissen noch immer nicht
worauf sie eigentlich achten sollen
nächster halt ist das ostel
dort kann man den zimmern übernachten
die aussehen wie früher in ost-berlin
wäre das thema angucken
so sahen früher eine wohnung in
ostdeutschland aus alles original
ich finde es cool das ist fast wie eine
zeitreise
ich bin zufrieden und ich
aber team nord ist auch fleißig gerade
fahren sie durch berlin tiergarten
vorbei an einem museum für gaslaternen
und der siegessäule
nach einer kurzen fahrt durchs grüne
landen sie bei einem museum in dem es um
die wurst geht
hier können die drei testen ob sie
talent zum currywurst verkäufer haben
danach hätten beide diktaturen am selben
platz vor dem brandenburger tor sehen
sich beide teams das erste mal wieder
das klärt sich jetzt der berliner bär
hält in seinen tatzen die allerletzte
aufgabe für beide teams markiert auf dem
stadtplan den start und zielort der
rikscha fahrt sowie eure beiden
zwischenstopps jetzt zeigt sich welches
team am besten aufgepasst hat und welche
mannschaft sich am schnellsten einig ist
dass der pariser ich mir ganz sicher
sein
nur wer sich die vier orte ganz genau
gemerkt hat kann diese aufgabe lösen
es geht dabei um viel dennoch können
beide teams bei ticket nach berlin
gewinnen
ltd